MICHAEL VAN
OUWERKERK: If you ask
a room of developers what mobile
device features are missing
from the web, push notifications
are always high on the list.
And it makes sense.
Push notifications are a great
way to reengage the user.
Push notifications are now
available on the open web
through a new set of web APIs.
I'm Michael, and I'm an
engineer on the Push API
team for Chrome.
And I'm going to show
you how to add push
notifications to your web app.
To start with, you
take a normal web page
and register a
service worker which
will handle your push messages.
Then you subscribe the
user to push messages,
which will register the user
device with the Push service
and give you some
information which you store
on your application server.
When your server is ready to
send a push message to users,
you call an API on
the Push service
to trigger a push message.
The Push service will
then send a push message
to the user device, which will
wake up your service worker
and fire a push event.
Then, in your event handler,
you show a notification.
And done.
The first thing we
need to do is set up
a project on the Google
Developer Console.
This is required to use push
notifications with Chrome,
because there isn't a
standard API for push services
to support yet.
Hopefully, when the
standard is finalized,
Chrome and GCM can support it.
Go to Console at
developers.google.com
to create a new project so
that you can use a GCM API.
In your new project, enable
Google Cloud Messaging
for Android and Google
Cloud Messaging for Chrome
on the APIs and auth, and create
a new public API access key.
Make a note of the
API key, as well as
the project number, which
you can find on the overview
page in your project.
To let Chrome know about
your GCM project number,
add a web app
manifest to your site.
The web app manifest
is a simple JSON file
that can be used to define icons
and the name of your web app.
For Push, you need to
define a GCM sender
ID in your manifest,
which is the project
number we mentioned before.
Add a link tag pointing
to your manifest
so Chrome knows
where to find it.
You can learn more
in this article.
Now that the GCM bit
is done, the next step
is to register a service
worker in your web page.
Don't worry if you're
new to service workers.
We'll be stepping through how
to use them for Push shortly.
But for more
in-depth details, you
can check Jake Archibald's talk.
Call a navigator.servic
eWorker.register,
passing in the location of
your service worker file.
This will tie a service
worker to your page.
Once it's registered, you
need to set up your UI.
So let's imagine we
have a toggle switch
to enable or disable Push.
For browsers which
don't support Push,
we should disable the switch
by checking if PushManager
exists on the window.
The next step is to subscribe
the user to the Push service.
We do this when the user
toggles the switch on.
Again, do
serviceWorkerRegistration,
and with the
registration we call
subscribe on the pushManager.
We've pass in
(userVisibleOnly: true)
because Chrome
only supports push
messaging with a notification.
In other words, you have
to show a notification when
you receive a push message.
When we call
subscribe, the browser
will show a permission prompt.
So make sure it's
obvious to the user
why this prompt is being shown.
The last thing you
want to do is show
a permission dialog when the
user first lands on your page.
They have no idea what it is.
If the user gives
you permission,
you will receive a
subscription object,
and you'll need to send
the endpoint variable
to your server, as this will be
needed to send a push message.
Time to send a push message.
Now that you have registered
with the Push service
and have an endpoint,
you simply need
to call this endpoint from
your application server.
Here, we'll look at a
simple cURL command,
but you'll need to implement
this in your chosen server
language.
For GCM, take the endpoint,
parse out the subscription ID,
and make a RESTful API
call to the GCM endpoint,
using your public API key
as an authorization header
and passing in the
subscription ID
inside the
registration_ids field.
Right now, nothing's
going to happen yet
when you send a push
message, because we
don't have our service worker
set up to handle the event.
Let's see what a
push event looks
like in the service worker.
For those of you who are
new to Service Workers,
you can think of them as
special JavaScript files
that the browser knows about
and executes in the background
without needing the
web app to be open.
The browser will start
up your service worker
when it receives a push
message in the special push
event, which you can listen
for it with an event listener.
It's inside this event listener.
We can display a notification.
It's worth noting that, when
you receive a push message,
you need to show a notification.
Otherwise, Chrome will show
its own notification, which you
won't have any control over.
To create your own
notification, you
need to call
showNotification, passing
in a title and a
set of parameters
to define the notification's
message and icon.
Notification tag is optional.
It can be used to
replace notifications
with the same tag.
One thing to really focus on
is the event.waitUntil method.
You need to pass in
the return promise
from showNotification,
as this tells the browser
to keep the Service Worker alive
until the promise is settled.
And that's it.
You can now send push messages
and show notifications.
There is one more thing.
You need to allow your users to
unsubscribe from push messages.
To unsubscribe
from Push, we need
to get the subscription
object, which
we can do by calling
getSubscription
on a pushManager.
Then call unsubscribe on
a subscription object.
It's at this point you
want to remove the endpoint
from your database.
This has been a quick
introduction into the Push API.
We look forward to seeing
what you will build.
Please go check out these
articles, which cover
all of this in more detail.
Thanks for watching.